[Applaudissements]
première répétition dans la salle de
spectacle pour les enfants les adultes
et l'ensemble des guitares du
conservatoire de maurepas qui célèbre
ses 50 ans concert d'ouverture des
festivités
immersion 1972 met en avant les musiques
de cette année la date également d'une
opération du conservatoire
on était avant de disco c'était encore
la grande variété et la grande variété
française d'autres françois michel
fugain véronique sanson donc j'ai fait
une sélection de petits morceaux et j'ai
fait des arrangements pour guitare cela
fait 33 ans que ce professeur de musique
enseigne la guitare au conservatoire de
maurepas c'est lui qui a eu l'idée de ce
concert il a en tout une soixantaine
d'élèves comme alexandra bridel qui joue
de cet instrument depuis 15 ans tous les
toutes les semaines on a une heure dans
semble donc pour s'entraîner sur ses
morceaux après là c'est vrai qu'on a une
quinzaine de morceaux presque et c'est
un très gros projet à monter on y est
depuis septembre
donc après avec les entraînements ça va
l'asb a du coup vous avez vu qu'on
s'entraîne avec les choristes avec les
musiciens donc c'est là que ça devient
un peu plus compliqué parce que c'est
vrai que quand on est entre nous c'est
facile parce que souvent on joue entre
nous depuis des années
deux fois par semaine les élèves
répètent entre eux ce concert d'une
durée d'une heure trente les placent
parfois aux instruments sans chanteur
associés
[Musique]
m
en ce moment vous entendez imagine avec
le thème au saxophone donc on a mis en
valeur différentes classes
instrumentales et puis moi pour les
chanteurs donc j'ai voulu faire
apparaître les voix d'enfants dans fais
comme l'oiseau
[Musique]
ouais
et
[Musique]
les chansons seront entrecoupées de
saynètes théâtrales ce concert
d'inauguration sera joué vendredi 4 et
samedi 5 février à l'espace albert camus
à mort
[Musique]